yeah i got a job at boeing in long beach
because that was as close as i could get
and then i would like commute up at
night i would work you know engineering
by day and then i would you know take
the 710 trucking route from long beach
to like the comedy store
just did that for a long time until i
was able to do this [ __ ] full time
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god
hola with me george lopez
let's do the show
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg bye
hey everybody this is producer grant
here just reminder if you like the show
if you're enjoying the show please like
comment subscribe on any platform you're
checking it out on whether that's on
youtube whether that's apple podcast
spotify anything any engagement that we
have really really helps we all serve
the almighty algorithm these days and
any amount that you sort of interact
with the show in any way just really
helps us out helps us get cooler guests
for the show helps raise the profile for
the show helps give us more content for
you guys to enjoy so thanks again for
checking it out and please enjoy the
episode you know
it's usually the the mexicans that are
late but come on in but come on you
thought it was 4 30. yeah
nice to do man
how are you man
uh
i'm good it's nice to meet you it's a
pleasure this is an honor man
yeah
uh
do you drink beer uh yeah i'll do beer
sure no what kind would you make i'll do
it you darren one of these ricky
ricky's our waitress ricky next week you
[ __ ] heels and i was like a little
scooter
like a catholic girl skirt the first
let's go
comedian what are you drinking in there
just water the water it's great
[Laughter]
comedian for here we are joining us on
the podcast today pop that little
[ __ ] hose out of there straight body
looks like the guy's drinking like you
know uh uh
an elixir uh uh from the [ __ ]
himalayas it's [ __ ] water
uh refreshing fresh um just filming you
know the gadgets that you kids have
these days we didn't have that [ __ ]
right there no he just wasn't in there
we had
a thermos
yeah and it was glass inside the glass
were to keep the liquid hot and if you
bounced it it still looked great on the
outside it feels like the glass is
broken
drinking glass so yeah
the glass was to keep it warm and cold
like that yes maintain the heat but then
when you would take a drink of coffee
you could hear [ __ ] glass like
and all those thermoses had a
top
your that was the coffee cup
it was either to pour your coffee in or
your liquor you drink it right out of
here now it's all about this yeah this
is the thermoflux right will you
introduce our guests and stuff [ __ ]
talk about your water
[Laughter]
my bad my bad uh comedian faheem anwar
joining us on the podcast today
um
you know let me ask you let me ask a
question i'm sure your dad asked you
why would somebody who was an engineer
who had a really good job want to leave
that to become a comedian i saw a
picture of your dad by the way oh
uh they sent it to me and your dad looks
and
you
did
like you're his dad my dad all our dads
it's like every immigrant dad
mustache like magnum p.i stash
they can't say porn because his was
thicker
retired from porn like he was like hey
but also he didn't have a did your dad
ever have a goatee no just stash as long
as i remember why is that do you think
that that is it is that cultural i think
they just grew up in an era where that
was the [ __ ] you know like think about
all the hot like sound like a magnum pi
i'm trying to think like who's that i
was a fan of tom selleck
i don't know about salad but like but
it's of the era you know what i mean
like that male machismo are you feeling
the united states no afghanistan but i
feel like don't you think that like that
was an era where mustaches were way
cooler than they are now you know i
can't
i can't see any of my dad's friends
with girls or anything like that one
time my dad shaved
he did it was fun why because he feels
weird [ __ ] because he was trimming it
and he [ __ ] it up and he said oh maybe
maybe but i think sometimes you just
want to change so he's like clean-shaven
is it religious it's not religious
listen man you guys i've seen you guys
grow yourselves up so i think my
mustache
white people took over with the ar-15
they just sort of they're like steph
curry they just they took it over but
you guys never blew each other you never
blew them it never blew each other
did that ever blow up no no no not him
but other people in the neighborhood
no yeah yeah so so in in in our culture
if you you know my grandfather would
would trim it and if he
nicked it too
close he would shave it off and i was
like what the matter you [ __ ] it up
and he goes yeah
but it was just like that was their
working thing forever like the most i
can't grow mine yeah well like
nah it'll come in all wispy it's okay
when it's short but if i let it grow for
longer than a week i just look like a
malnourished taliban soldier like it's
no good but it's okay
hey i didn't blow myself up i'm still
around
so so
were you born in the united states yeah
i was born in okay seattle area um
give me a little bit of your f of your
your you and your mom your mother and
your father still married yeah yeah yeah
was it was an arranged marriage no no no
no
no
you know what latinos are all arranged
the girl is across the street you're
[ __ ] married
you know i've always thought like
you know americans and like white people
will take so much from like indian
culture and they'll be like you know
like yoga and all that stuff and gurus
and stuff when it comes to like arranged
marriages they go that's [ __ ] crazy
but everything else they just like all
the clothes
they're taking like incense they take
yeah
everything the police the the yoga the
yoga the
um uh
affirmations yeah yeah and uh beliefs
um
where did your mother follow me
uh they knew each other in afghanistan
yeah so yeah yeah and then
everything listen if you want to talk
about a guy who's a comedian you have to
go back to the history the origin story
oh yeah i always do this is a common
thread yeah yeah i always do and what
does your father do
he is an engineer at boeing okay and
what do you expect you to do you know
what would have made him happy doctor
100 doctor they always say doctor lawyer
engineers kind of like the lowest rung
you know
but the thing is i don't know a lot of
afghan like lawyers they always say
lawyer but it's always doctor doctors
what they want and and um when you were
growing up what what did you feel in
your in your heart that you would have
been happy doing
before any accommodate [ __ ] out that
[ __ ] like like when you were going
to school you were you know what you
know
when i was a kid i wanted to be in the
nba
there's i think every kid no matter what
your race is whatever your ethnicity you
want to be in the nba
and everyone just allows you to have
that dream for a while even though
genetically you're not going to like
change your cards that way but i
remember my uncle he's a cardiologist
but he wanted to be the nba nah he just
he heard me saying that i was gonna be
the nba and i'm gonna be in the nba and
he goes you're not gonna be in the nba
you're a mission
it was just like this harsh reality
that like everyone had been kid gloves
and get my whole life and like not
shattering my dream and just realizing
in that like dodge caravan ride home
that like
wait there's a chance that you're not
gonna be your heart yeah in your heart
you were like i could do that oh my god
yeah no nobody told you you couldn't
well when you're a little kid no one's
gonna it's like santa they're gonna let
you believe that you know what your
favorite who are your favorite players
well i grew up in seattle so sean kemp
gary payton uh those are my guys like
sometimes i'll go on youtube and watch
like
what happened how old are you 38. um
um
why did they leave seattle the the
the supersonics well it was like a bait
and switch like they made it seem like
they were going to be kept the the um
howard schultz the starbucks guy so he
sold the team
to i forgot what the guy's name is
some like oklahoma city business guy and
they made it seem like it was going to
stay in the city and then they ended up
taking them
to oklahoma and so that you know we were
you don't have a professional team out
there right no no we haven't had it for
a longest time we're due for one
when did this when did the supersonics
when the uh nba championship like with
london
yeah yeah yeah yeah i said don't
[ __ ] don't say it a long time
well first i know
well
they had downtown freddie brown and they
had sigma those guys like 79
i was in i was a senior in high school
nice
who's your team uh the lakers nice that
makes sense that checks out yeah but i
was a fan of of basketball like
supersonics were good they had a good
team they had good teams i mean yeah we
took the bulls the finals i mean
i felt like that was going to be it but
and who were your favorite players
growing up those guys yeah gary payton
jordan you know you like did you ever
see michael jordan play basketball no
that's my one regret like
my two regrets like not seeing jordan
play life and never seeing a michael
jackson concert
because like i loved michael growing up
and just to know that i will never be
able like him in prince remember when
prince did a run in la he did like 50
shows
at like the hollywood bowl or somewhere
like really cheap taking introduced them
to the first night whoa
we were friends you know wow
yeah and i testified uh in michael
jackson's trial in 2005. jeez we'll get
to that if you want to holy [ __ ] any
slam just someone who's like one degree
away from michael this is like did you
stay michael
yeah and he [ __ ] me
that's how you gain entry uh before i
got in the house
uh we were in the movie uh theater place
um
so are you musical do you play
nah here's the thing what i like i feel
like when you're growing up you think
you can create music like i'm gonna make
beats and and then you realize at a
certain age but did you
were you in the so 38 so
did you
how did you get did you would you
were you and your friends like trying to
be djs now so i mean let's see what i
was in orchestra and i would play bass
so you were creative yeah kind of i mean
my first performance
i would do michael jackson at talent
shows so i would put on the billy jean
[ __ ] and i was like good at it when i
was a kid maybe maybe they're just
clapping because i'm a kid and it was
cute but i thought but it takes balls
man to go up there in front of your in
front of the student body yeah you know
and and
did you put the glove on of course come
on fedora sparkly glove my mom made me a
sparkly glove
and i would always do it before the asb
elections
because it would always happen like
right around then and then people would
love me from the michael jackson dance
and then they would vote for me and
that's how i would win did you uh powder
your face or did you go natural i do
white face i'm going i'm going home
no no no no no no
you had the sequin jacket i had yeah you
know first you try to keep it as there
were high water pens yeah totally man
white socks black slacks and what did
you do
that's the only song to do yeah this is
the only song come on the whole build up
where the beat drops and you got the
fedora and then you take it up
and you whip it of course
that song
that song and performance is a
masterclass in like building tension
he's not doing a lot at the beginning
what about that chrissy jones said i
don't like that long introduction he
said that yeah he said you get you got
to get rid of it this thing is what's
useless
what are we doing this is [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is that no it's like hey we're
leaving it in and they bumped heads well
it's almost like trance music there'll
be a [ __ ] like minute and a half
lead up to the beat dropping and people
love that [ __ ] did the jax's tour in
seattle addicted
i don't know i think i was too young to
i don't know
he stopped i said he stopped playing uh
his last concert was 20
uh
like 2003
two one
i went to the super bowl in 1993 and he
was holy [ __ ]
the buffalo bills and the dallas cowboys
and he performed at halftime is that the
one where like the michael double comes
up on the top of the jumbotron oh [ __ ]
yeah is that the one too where he pops
out on stage and people are cheating yes
he doesn't move a muscle and people are
cheering for and then he takes this yeah
i'm a huge michael jackson fan as well
so i i love that performance
and at the comedy store when we would do
open mic sometimes you just do crazy off
the wall [ __ ] cause who cares it's three
minutes you know one time i went up and
did that like michael jackson so i just
had the mirrored sunglasses and i had
them play sounds of applause so it
wasn't even the crowd didn't even have
to applaud so i would just be up there
and i had the cd playing for like a
minute of just applause and then i took
my sunglasses up and there was another
pair of sunglasses underneath it and
then more applause i just love that
performance
so yeah i mean
that's good yeah and he i think he lip
sank it uh because they do at at the
halftime because you can't rely on mics
and all that stuff so they yeah
he was but he was still really amazing i
heard like that performance is kind of
what changed super bowl performances
before it was hard to get people to
perform and they didn't treat it like
like that big of a thing but after
michael
it has evolved into like what we see
today because before performances
weren't like that they would have
marching bands and [ __ ] it wasn't like
super glossy pop star stuff yeah
were you a fan of michael jackson
i did i liked the well you see him i
like never never in person i liked the
jackson five and then i followed michael
after that but i never did go see him
why do you think that he changed his
look so much
i have no i i thought he was trying to
resemble diana ross for the longest time
but he passed donna he was all into like
club
what do you what era i like asking
people this what era michael do you
think was the best like he should have
stopped just visually
um
that's a really good question
uh
i mean when he listen after he got
burned
his life was never the same because you
burned the top of his head
and all your nerves are on the top of
your head and he had the whole jerry
curl yeah thing and you know he's like
was never not him he never had a day
after that that he wasn't in pain
so then he relied on
um you know pills to relieve the pain
but then also he was very different
after that
so if he wasn't burned
uh
i think his career would have been
would have been very different
what arrow was that he got that was like
84
post thriller
pretty bad yeah 84. january 27th 84.
and they had it in the can already the
guy goes let's do it one more time
and that's what the guy back then when
they had pyrotechnics
he wasn't
the guy hit the pirate tactics before
he got to
he should have already been down the
stairs and he wasn't
and it caught his hair on fire
man
i think thriller mike that was the peak
i think maybe visual and like music
yeah yeah
how did you
form that relationship how did that
happen
well i got subpoenaed
and
at the comedy store jamie masada had a
comedy camp for kids
in the 2000s and me and arsenio chris
tucker jay leno jamie foxx would have
these families assigned to us i got
assigned
the the
kids
and the mom was a very
adolescent woman she was kind of like uh
very childlike
and they were dirt poor
and i had them and i got them and then
so we would go for like a month or two
months and give them tips on how to do
stand-up and then one night they would
do a show and the kids did great so
everybody goes their family goes and
they do stand up and those kids were all
right
next thing i know
um i get a call from the mom she's all
freaked out that is in the children's
hospital on sunset he has a tumor in his
stomach and then i go over there and he
took out like a football-sized tumor in
the stomach and then i arranged a blood
drive at my daughter's school
and fox news covered it and michael
jackson saw the story on fox
and
fit the profile of what he liked
in a boy
and michael jackson called fox
got the number of the family and then i
went to go see like three days later
and during the day he was asleep wiped
out and i said what's the matter
what's my how to be sleeping oh he was
on the phone with michael last night for
like five hours and i'm like uh
michael
oh oh michael jackson called he saw the
story on fox and he called us here and
him been talking like from midnight to
six a.m for the last three nights
uh michael jackson calls at midnight and
he stays on the phone for six hours yeah
okay
and then
uh
michael jackson used
his power to
take the family to neverland ranch
uh one one or two times as a family and
then he said to the kids ask your mom if
you can stay here over the weekend
and then they did and he gave the father
a truck and gave the mom a credit card
and said go in and go shopping and you
and they can stay here and that was
he was grooming uh he was
grooming
which which is uh you know uh
which uh you think you know if you're an
entertainer you ever like any fat kids
let me ask the ship and say
so there was a uh so there was a a
method to his to his
sure i mean the kids that he like the
kids that he liked were fit a profile
and a certain look and they were from uh
families that weren't doing so well
financially because he would use his
resources to get the get earn the
family's trust
to do
but i saw him in court and uh
i walked into i walked into court
and i'm standing there they're on a
break so i'm the next i was i just got
there
i just got sworn i got i just got there
i went through the metal detector sent
it back to the courthouse they were in
recess i'm the next guy in on the
to be the witness
and i'm looking around
because they're on a break i go where
does that move okay look over there and
i'm like
he
he looked like a [ __ ] nutcracker
he was wearing like black and white
pee-wee herman type pants
and a red jacket i know you're talking
about yeah yeah yeah and
he he was standing very he looked like a
[ __ ] that a nutcracker you put by the
fireplace imagine being that famous
where you look in the mirror and you go
yeah that's good
so like sometimes i'll wear a v-neck and
i go this this might be too slow like
i'm out and about with the v-neck and i
go i gotta go home and change this guy's
[ __ ] he's got epilepsy
he was he was
the color of this computer his skin was
that color this is gunmetal gray damn
and and when you're old like me and you
remember what he was like when he was a
kid
and you see
that guy sitting at the at the [ __ ]
defendant's bench and try he had no lips
like he had his lips removed jesus so
he's looking there and he's he's like
it's like a scale you know when you're
on an emoji there's a skeleton like i'm
dead you're a skeleton so imagine
that with like a skeleton with the thing
and
no lips and he was trying to get my
attention so he was going like this and
he would be like this with the
with no lips
he looked like a [ __ ] ghoul like he
looked like a
for the next three weeks i woke in the
middle of the night i had nightmares
about
what
that kid that we saw growing up was in
that body and what that dude had to go
through
to end up
like that sometimes and in court
for looking at you know being put away
for a long time yeah
sometimes you see somebody like that
who's so famous and they seemingly have
everything you could ever want but
you look at the way that their life kind
of pans out and you know what do you
think causes that you what do you think
you know what i think because another
person like that
is like you'll see is it ego is it no
here's what it is like uh
nothing lasts forever even the most
famous person in the world
it's you're going to evaporate like i'm
trying who's bigger like ryan gosling
100 years from now no one's going to
give a [ __ ]
yeah so time is undefeated um no matter
how big you get you're gonna be a blip
on the timeline of the universe and the
thing is
these people can't let go they want it
to be that forever and they can't
realize that all right i'm entering a
new phase of my life and it's okay like
i can't burn this fast and bright
like it's impossible you're defying the
laws of physics but because they want to
hold on to it for as long as possible
that's when you see the ghoulishness or
you know you're trying to reverse time
and you can't okay so
uh hey some of this i'm gonna tell the
truth on some stuff some more air we'll
see
so so
aeg
was my promoters the guy that owned
staple the guys that owned staples
and that's where michael jackson was
doing
the uh shows for aeg they were gonna go
to london right yeah
michael jackson's father brought his
sidekick this other african-american guy
to meet with the executives of aeg
and
they said
if he goes to london you have to pay us
because i have a contract with them it's
like you don't have a [ __ ] contract
we're not giving you [ __ ]
so
they had to get michael and his father
and aeg in the same room
michael jackson saw his dad and he threw
up
wow
he went to the bathroom and he threw up
whoa
and they go and he goes what's the
matter
i can't i can't talk to i can't talk
with my father in the room he said
michael yeah the lawyers are there you
have to tell them that he's he he's not
part of it like they have to be told by
you
you he your father's not in your
business
he [ __ ] threw up when he saw him wow
so
michael jackson heavy drug user
and and
uh
years ago
before before he was still alive i went
to
las vegas about 2005 or six
and
i had my kidney transplant and i had a
that's swelling and i had to get a
diuretic
so i told the lady that that works for
my foundation linda said i need to find
a direct let me see if i can find you a
doctor so she's gone she comes back
three hours later she comes with a
prescription and she says i met this
doctor
and he wanted me to tell you
that whatever you need i'll get you and
i said what do you mean and she goes no
no that that's what i said what do you
mean you said tell george i can get him
liquid demerol percocet cocaine liquid
cocaine any norcolds whatever he wants
that doctor's name
conrad murray
wow
so conrad murray
could write prescriptions as a doctor
when it got to the point where they were
going to start to leave to london
michael jackson was in bad shape and
even that movie
this is it
he wasn't capable of doing
50 shows he wasn't capable of doing five
shows and he knew it
and he knew it
and now already the director had sent
emails going hey this [ __ ] right
here i don't know
you got to come and see we might have to
think about rescheduling whatever we're
not rescheduling [ __ ] well oh there's so
much money everyone's gonna probably
it's gonna be weakening bernie's
so
um
the last night that he was alive he
hugged that dude randy
when he before he got in the car and he
said thank you
i know i can do it now
and
he died overnight oh man i think
my
opinion
i think he committed suicide
i think he knew in his heart that he
wasn't going to be able to do 50 shows
and the rubber had met the road to the
point where he
he wasn't even going to be on the stage
that long
but he wasn't going to be able to be on
the stage for 30 minutes much less 50
shows and he knew it
at some point
when you know it you're trying to avoid
the biggest embarrassment would which
would be
to go over there and fail
and he wanted to take conrad murray and
and randy was like [ __ ] that why don't
we take this guy get a doctor over there
no no i gotta have this guy michael then
you have to fly that guy playing per
diem put him up we'll find a [ __ ]
doctor in london has to be this guy no
has to be this guy
[ __ ] got in a fight with him because
he knew that that guy was his his
his enabler with the drugs but i i think
that
i think that he got up and pushed that
and pushed the
thing too you think it's a better way to
go
oh i don't want to let my fans down or
be a mockery because i can't do what i
do on stage i'm going to go out on top
like this sure very plausible very very
bullish because because
he's not a clear thinking dude like like
he can't go to sleep with [ __ ] that they
give people to go to sleep in surgery
and he's so his tolerance is so high for
a guy that he's like
you could
nobody takes propofol and stays awake
and i think he the guy was on the phone
stepped out he might have or not but i
think that he
i think that he may have ended his own
life
and he was a performer since he was like
three so imagine being told the one
thing that was your whole life but also
when you're broken i mean it happens in
comedy when you're broken and just you
feel like there's no place for you to go
and nobody's on your side and the
disappointment is on a high level
you
you give up yeah that's the one
centering thing like we all have our
things michael had music and performing
and all that i think we have stand up
whatever's going through my life
whenever i get off stage it's so like ah
i have this you know what i mean
everything else works itself out because
you have this centering thing how did
you show me your your road to stand up
how how did you what what were you
how long have you been doing santa 20
years man oh wow yeah yeah
congratulations thanks for the [ __ ]
start you were 18. yeah damn i started
when i was 18. oh yeah and and where did
you go and and what was the who did you
tell and what came to you like my like
for me yeah uh my friend ernie was going
to kennedy high school out here and
there was a guy named don nielsen that
went to kennedy
uh and he was going on monday nights to
the common store in westwood and they
rolled a bottom in in ernie's school
paper and he brought that to me and he
said hey man the comedy store on monday
night this guy's going over there you
and i had to go over there and that's
where he fed me the idea uh well how did
you get the idea to be to do stand-up
you know i didn't really grow up with
stand-up albums or anything but i grew
up with like snl i loved that show and
then when i
when i was around 17 i was just like how
do people get on that show it was just
just this otherworldly thing i go how
does that happen
and i researched they came from improv
comedies so like ucb groundlings second
city
um or standups like spade sandler kevin
neiland those were the two worlds and
then i researched all the improv schools
like second city they were all in
chicago new york or l.a i'm a kid in
seattle
so i don't live there and then you have
to pay money to take these classes and
it seems like there's a lot of
bureaucracy you need other people
stand up is just you i mean could you
teach
could picasso teach you how to paint no
like i'm not knocking improv you know
it's this other there's a skill set it's
very different than science it's very
different but can somebody teach
stand-up they can tell you where to go
and how to feel yeah but they can't you
got swim unless you got the brush in
your head you somebody could tell you
this is how you do it yeah i'm a big fan
of just you know put your
jump into the fire figure it out what
i'm just being a fan of like i'll
[ __ ] go do it i'll that's how you
learn now cause i always had this
performance element to me like i told
you about the michael jackson thing i
would always like that was my first
entrance into performance it was like
dancing like michael jackson so i would
i would do that
and i liked making sketches i liked
making little videos and stuff and video
productions in eighth grade so i had
that bug already and then i loved snl
and then i saw delirious i think my 17th
birthday 17th or 18th birthday we rented
delirious amazing uh eddie murphy's
delirious if nobody knows yep um you
should know if you don't know so
that was the first time stand-up kind of
came on my radar i was like holy [ __ ]
this is amazing
and then you remember when you saw it
for the first time yeah i was my parents
upstairs uh like romper room or whatever
you're all dying me and my buddies and
my brother just [ __ ]
hilarious amazing
and then i was like i'm gonna do stand
up so then i did stand up at this like
comedy night at my school
i did like 30 minutes for my first time
but i did well
yeah yeah
but like looking back it probably was
gone awful
but you know
30 minutes is a long way too long it's
way too long for now even you know
but then i kept going that summer so i
graduated
uh you know senior year and then that
summer i just i went to the comedy
underground
a few times and then you just do a thing
for long enough and you kind of start in
that scene you would go up there and do
and do open mics and yeah open mic
signing right out of the bucket yeah
and then just you know like i'm off to a
flame i just really
what did your father think or your
mother think when you said you know they
they liked it when i when it just was
part of a school thing you know like
they like me doing drama they like me
doing that but then once it seemed like
oh he might want to do this as a career
it was just like a big like [ __ ] did
this
did they yell at you like oh yeah
oh wow yeah so it was like doing heroin
pretty much
for real there you go that's a that's a
good one telling your parents you wanted
to do comedian they treated you like
you're [ __ ] heroin hell do you know
because i would you could smoke in the
clubs at the time i would come home and
i feel like my mom like your hair smells
like smoke
and like your father's worried about you
you said you said hey i gotta tell you
guys something um i'm a comedian i want
to be a comedian
i think they knew they knew but the
thing is i was still going to
engineering school and i was getting
good grades so they couldn't really
yeah you were still doing enough yeah i
was doing enough they didn't like it but
i was still getting my degree and it was
it was fine you know but they still
would have loved if i was just like a
doctor
yeah you got your degree got my degree
and then i applied the jobs in southern
california because i knew i had so you
said i'm moving to california so you
moved to california yeah i got a job at
boeing in long beach because that was as
close as i could get and then i would
like commute up at night i would work
you know engineering by day and then i
would you know take the 710 trucking
route from long beach to
like the comedy store just did that for
a long time till i was able to do this
[ __ ] full time
and what did you tell your boss when you
were going to leave i think it was a
long time coming so when it finally
happened they were like
they couldn't they were mad
in the earlier years this is just like
fruit like coming to fruition but but
you were did they ever go see you
perform do they go see you work no not
really yeah
i want them to come see me like for a
big thing like i do the tonight show or
something even though the tonight show
is not what it was anymore it would be
cool to put a suit on have my family in
the crowd and just be a nice celebration
where would that happen now and jimmy
kimmel
i mean l.a jimmy kimmel yeah oh who else
but even then i just feel like to your
points like the cachet of doing a sort
of late night set is just sure i've done
like three already like
what did you do i did conan twice and i
did seth meyers that was my first one
you know what's crazy i sometimes i go
down youtube rabbit holes and i saw your
arsenio from like way back in the day
was great and doing the couch and [ __ ]
yeah yeah was that your first late night
uh
yes in 89 so how did that i'm curious
like your path and trajectory so how did
that come to be
on my path you're not i'll tell you if
you want to know but but
um
in your heart like did you feel like
because
i i never get off stage and say god i
feel
so much better now that i did that like
i
i used to stand up almost like a boxer
that was trying to get out of the
neighborhood uh i didn't look at it as
uh i'm being creative i don't even know
why i even i mean i like stand-up
but
i wasn't connected to it in any way
other than to try to get out
you know yeah
so so i was like it was like the nba to
you just like i was getting out of my
schedule
but but i didn't think it didn't come
natural to me that you were a performer
it didn't come natural to me
i
uh
met some guys that i knew forever in 79
but it wasn't something that
i ever felt comfortable doing i just
kept doing it
but think about like you know when we
start there's no
benefit there's no money if every time
you did he did a thousand dollars i'll
be back tomorrow yeah [ __ ] it i hate to
check man thanks a thousand dollar i'll
be back tomorrow see you this weekend
but you go to a place where you're not
good and you keep going
what does that say about us like where
where is that hole in our body that we
need to feel
with strangers and people you don't know
and you're staying up there yeah and
you're trying to get them to laugh so
you feel better at making them laugh for
me it's the puzzle of it
i like when i'm working on a bit and
then maybe a part of it works and the
other part puts them off and they don't
like you with that bit then i'm like oh
okay i went too far
let me refine this an engineer would
look at it
yeah yeah and do you want to be uh uh
what what do you aspire to be now that
you know you've been with chappelle you
do those shows very eclectic
the highest uh level comedians and what
what do
what would make you happy if you're 38
how about being at 48 or 58 what what
where do you where would you see your
perfect self
you know like just enough um
i don't need a lot yeah i think married
yeah okay
i think all i ever wanted out of this
game was just to make a decent living
being creative and doing something you
love so you could be behind the scenes
if you created a show you could be
maybe if it's
my [ __ ] yeah you know like if it's my
vision
and it's on screen cool but sometimes in
hollywood you can they want you to show
run something and it's not your project
and then then you're making a lot of
money but it's not your vision right
even something as simple as like a bit i
think of tonight or like here here like
here at this podcast and then i go do it
tonight that's exciting like oh [ __ ] i
just thought of that earlier today yep
and now the rubber meets the road right
but if it's somebody else's show like
hey this is some 25 year old kid show do
you want to run it and i'm talking to
costumes and i'm talking to like the
gaffers like that then it's like boeing
did you run a show
no but i know that's a route you know
and also you know let me give you some
problems i also use the term when the
rubber meets the road it's a good it's a
good way to put up like boxers at some
point i try to try to tell everybody
with stand-up uh you can work and work
and work but at some point
you got to put them up and you got to
[ __ ] do it yeah it's just you and the
audience that's what i love about it
because hollywood there's all this
there's agents there's managers there's
casting directors there's
various producers on a project there's
so many places where you get lost in
translation but what's great about
stand-up is like it's just you a stage
the idea
it's so immediate
are you do you do you write sketches
more or do you write jokes or what
what's your uh like let's see
uh i was never political
as a comedian yeah not really yeah but
when trump started to run and then he
the first day he said oh you know
mexicans are criminals and they're
rapists and then you know
i got activated yeah yeah i'm the same
way i don't really slant political but
if i have an idea i'll do it but i'm not
like bill maher or something yeah yeah
and if that's not your bread and butter
you're just dividing half the crowd for
no reason especially if that's not your
strength so you know in in in doing
stand-ups since 1979
and going through i mean when i first
stepped on stage jimmy carter was a
[ __ ] president
so
three years ago three and a half years
ago
i went to took cedric's family to go eat
at the chateau and
when um
uh number 45
had assassinated the leader and i in ira
and i iran
and there was a story on that saturday
that said that iran had offered a 80
million dollar bounty
so i after lunch i turned my phone on
and i saw that on hollywood unlocked and
i typed
we'll do it for half
and by the time i got home i published
this call and said uh
did you
say something
about the president uh 45 minutes ago
yeah yeah what did you say
uh they offered 80 million and i said
we'll do it for half yeah well
it's all over the place it's on fox
there are people calling for you to be
arrested get the [ __ ] out of here no
serious it's all over the place it's
everywhere
and i said well well what's gonna happen
and they said well fox wants to know
or wanna they want an answer from you i
said it's a [ __ ] joke i'm a comedian
it's a joke yeah
then i'm at the doctor's office and
they're watching fox in there and it
says that i was i'm going to get
a visit the guy said uh well comedian
george lopez should be expecting a visit
from the
secret service and i'm like the [ __ ]
secret for what and they came to my
house no
what did they say
well first of all don't do that first of
all they have everything we've ever put
on on social media all of it
all yours all yours all of ours
they come in they go we're here to just
assess whether you're a threat or not
okay
uh do you remember uh retweeting a
picture
of el chapo holding a severed head
of the president and i said
uh what's the guy's name el chapo
holding what
uh i said you know
i have to tell you i i
i don't remember
[ __ ] opened his briefcase took
out his dossier
took a picture does this refresh your
memory someone printed it off
the secret service did
and they showed it to me and it had what
i said that i said oh this
and he said do you think that this is
funny i said
not right now there you go look how many
retweets it got i said when i did it i
thought it was funny but right now i'm
not finding it very amusing
and
uh everything that i had said i said i
also said but they [ __ ] didn't want
to my head cut off it'll give me [ __ ]
[ __ ] crying
so uh uh
they
how many people
what do you mean how many people showed
up uh two two guys were they nice or
were they kind of intimidating uh one
was a good one and one was a battle oh
they still do that they said to me uh do
you have any weapons in the house i'm
sorry i'm sorry do you have any weapons
in the house
weapons uh guns
no
i do yeah
but
they should if you heard that you were
the officer detective yeah you know i'm
[ __ ] lying right there right yes you
have any guns in the house take too long
for you to answer yeah so
in our age of you know
politicians can be looked at as fools
and we're looked at as the truth we were
never there you're a comedian
does any of that go into your into
thoughts with your as your writing yeah
i mean i had this one thought i did on
stage where i'm like you know sometimes
people will be like what can what
responsibility do comedians have and i'm
like none
we should like i play both sides like
i'm married to the joke like if i appear
republican in one joke if to make the
joke work okay if i appear liberal in
one joke to make the joke work okay i'm
a jester man i'm playing all sides of it
but but
everybody's you know now they're so such
a divide to the right and the left
yeah that
i went to the when the astros played the
dodgers i went to every game of the
world series and i was flying back from
that great game that sunday game where
the dodgers last when the [ __ ] astros
were hitting garbage cans together yeah
yeah
curveball you know who knew they were
cheating like stomp i was like 15 to 15
to 13.
uh and there was a big guy texas dude 6
15 in the morning walks up to me [ __ ]
big guy you george lopez yes [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] trump [ __ ]
the best thing that ever happened to
america you go back to [ __ ] mexico
where the [ __ ] you came back from i said
[ __ ] you [ __ ] for a [ __ ] gay
well [ __ ] you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] hillbilly [ __ ] and he's like
[ __ ] you and i turn around to my greeter
it's a little latina girl and she's
holding my boarding pass and she's like
and she said you know that guy said dude
no i don't mean that like he why did he
say that well because he's a [ __ ] red
hat yeah yeah
wow it's weird sometimes i get so
triggered and like when i get political
sometimes it's very kid gloves like it's
a jokey joke
because you know that if you go deeper
that you you'll you'll get some push
sure but even on like the surface level
jokey joke they got triggered one time i
was doing the la jolla comedy store and
i had this joke where i'm like uh it
feels weird to say trump is our
president it's like saying hulk hogan is
our lawyer or he's my lawyer you know
just like a dumb joke and some light
like this old white lady in the back's
like he's uh he's unamerican
get him off stage he's on american and
they had to like bounce her she was like
yelling the whole way that's what that
dude did
he gave everybody a right
to stand up and say i don't like that
oh yeah i got family like that i don't
talk to him anymore
how about that but that was such like a
nothing joke like it barely went into
politics like everyone else was loving
it even like republicans in the crowd
but like sometimes they're just waiting
to have this fight you know
should you be at a comedy club if you're
waiting to have a fight no i did a live
hbo special
at the kennedy center
a couple miles from the white house i
said donald trump called us rapists and
criminals and when i see him i'm gonna
rob him and [ __ ] him
raw because that's the way he likes it
and uh
i did it live nobody told me hbo didn't
tell me not to do it
i did it was this before or after the
tweet
yeah uh before they come to your house
again by the way i just think that's a
funny line i don't give a [ __ ] if it was
trump bite whoever that's a that's a
good line i said you better build that
wall in one day because you'd leave that
[ __ ] material out there overnight
that [ __ ] will [ __ ] be gone
[Laughter]
and i wasn't political like it it
changed you know i was a
you know i was a guy trying to make it
you know i had an opportunity to do a
television show i did it was still on
but i was never
and then you have people tell you my
kids love your show they will never
watch your show ever again
well i'm sorry
yeah sorry for them hey and it just
divided us to a point where i got in a
fight i was doing a movie in las cruces
new mexico i got in a fight with a
[ __ ] guy because he was live
streaming and he came over and put the
[ __ ] camera in my face and he's like
uh ma make america great i guess get the
[ __ ] out of here
and are you that well known as like it's
crazy that this many people are coming
at you no i don't mean like that i mean
like politically to just these mega guys
to come at you yeah they know who the
enemies are i think
it's like you know i don't play uh
highlight but if i did i guess i would
know who the best highlight player in
the world would be
but it's just it became a [ __ ]
minefield of [ __ ] and a minefield of
people
thinking that their voice mattered it
doesn't matter if you buy a ticket to
sit in the audience your laughs matter
your [ __ ] opinions don't matter and
that's how you get will smith slapping
[ __ ] chris rock yeah because it's
like it just can't be a joke yeah if you
don't like a joke just sit out you know
you got to get a medical record of
somebody oh you have alopecia i wish i
would have known
i'm sorry but
it destroys real comedy because a real
comedian is trying to get to the crust
of something the gist of something that
is
deeper than
just somebody just being up there just
to yeah take my wife please kind of go a
little deeper and also not every joke is
for everyone if you don't like that one
sit that one out that's right pop in for
the next one that's right i don't like
every drake track but i don't cancel
drake
you know what i mean i'm like i'll like
the next track
and uh um
do you go do you go on the road do you
do dates on starting too yeah so i had a
special come out on youtube and then i'm
gonna hit the road how did you do your
youtube special you know i just wanted
to do it at the comedy store just
because that's my home club and then you
told him i want to do the comedy story
yeah i called peter shore up because
i've had this idea for a while and like
i can't do it without their buy-in i
just wanted to film it during regular
operation like i didn't want to rent it
out and i didn't want my crowd to be
there or anything i just wanted to film
what it's like to do a regular set at
the comedy store so i do the original
room just my regular 15-minute set you
know original room main room belly room
just so you get a feel for the different
rooms very clever yeah so
that's all i wanted for a special is
just to be a fly on the wall at a comedy
club not like super produced and glossy
like i've done one of those already
i just wanted to capture what it's like
to work out at that gym you know yeah
yeah interesting
and how was it i was received it's great
yeah it's on my youtube channel and it's
nice to build
your youtube channel it's just my
youtube channel is
youtube.comanoir the special is called
hat trick so if you type in
or patrick it'll come up
have you seen it yeah it's a good
special yeah nice good it looks great
too like i directed it bro whoa man yeah
and what kind of cameras did you do how
much did it
cost a lot to do no no not really so
they didn't charge you to use a room or
anything no yeah because it was just
piggybacking on a regular night of
operation and it was super skeleton crew
i think you i think you might be the
first dude that i've ever heard of that
that has done that the hat trick to to
be able to ask somebody hey do you mind
if i well it was because it's for
youtube like i'm not making any money
off of this we didn't sell it to any
streamers
um
so i think because there was really no
money to be more of your your passion
project
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i'm a store guy
so
it's not like some i'm some outside
entity coming in trying to use the space
like they know me pretty well yeah were
you a store guy what was your club
coming up
um
that's a very good question
the first time i went on stage there was
a comedy store in westwood
on westwood boulevard right before
olympic it's our italian restaurant
right now and in that
comedy store was
john fox gary chandling
howie mandel tim thomason elaine boosler
uh
uh howie mandel
and you know you know the regular guys
but uh
it was a great place it wasn't the store
on sunset it was just kind of on in
westwood
very easy to be at very cool but you
know you aspired to go to hollywood and
uh so i went in there and then i went to
hollywood a little bit but i was 18 so
you know
i'd have to go on early and then be done
there was really nobody there so it
becomes very kind of like
you get you get down on you're gonna go
up there and just [ __ ] six people
they're seating people in three minutes
you're [ __ ] out like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
so uh but i was never uh i never felt
welcomed at the comedy store
so i haven't
the last time i performed at the comedy
store was
in 1991.
so man
and carlos mancilla stole my act
from that time that i was there
is that part of the reason you're like
didn't want to go back because he stole
no no no no i just didn't feel
comfortable there and then i was at the
ice house for a long time and i was kind
of you know there
doing the road and stuff and then i
started going to the lab factory it was
really kind of the lab factory maybe the
improv a little bit but
but you ever think about going back to
the store or you go it's not worth it um
no you know what they've asked me to go
back there they've called me and said
you know we have a spot well not
recently but they called me and they
would say we have a 10 20 spot
if you want to come down i said nah it's
so different you know it's crazy because
i'll hear these stories from like
legends and people who've come before
and these things happen to you kind of
in your formative years and then you'll
still hold on to these things even
though it's a completely different place
like i think seinfeld didn't perform at
the comedy store forever because like
mitzi didn't like him and then he's
friends with sebastian and then he came
down one time and performed there so
it's crazy that like did he feel like i
should be here more or did he feel like
wow that was great i mean everybody
knows who he is sure yeah he's like so
beyond that little blip in his career
that that you kind of put so much
importance on
uh but he did end up performing there he
doesn't perform there a lot he'll be at
the hollywood improv sometimes you know
here
um
but like yeah they would love it if you
came back and it's totally different
people and it's a fun space i mean it'd
be great to see you there
do it man do it
i saw some great people there ugh it's
awesome
i mean in the in the um
in 79 80
um
i was me and my buddy ernie were there
uh
and i saw
uh
david letterman
uh
howie
uh
tim thomerson
and a couple other guys standing in in
front of me maybe 10 feet like where the
wall is
and letterman was still doing like he
was doing i think a morning show you
know yeah
so i told my friend to have [ __ ]
letterman's over there man
and i didn't want to go up and ask him
for uh an autograph so a homeless guy
comes by
and i say to him
amen i'll give you five dollars you go
and ask that dude to sign this paper
he asked the wrong guy
he asked skip stevenson it said hey
you made skip steven
today you know uh
uh you know laugh more you know skip
steven said i said kids back i said not
him the other [ __ ] guy give him
another five dollars because i don't own
a tv i don't know so now he's standing
with a paper and a pen he's looking back
at us and looking i said
that guy right there
so he taps the guy [ __ ] letterman
looks at him goes yeah signs it gives it
to him comes back
and david letterman wrote uh
beat it you deadbeat
[Laughter]
david brenner that's what he wrote i
still have it
uh yeah amazing enough yeah he just had
a [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
but uh uh yeah it's almost like you know
i wasn't around in the prehistoric ages
but those guys their lore
is so big like i saw richard pryor in a
canary
yellow rolls royce listening to a set
between shows in his driver's seat
idling in front of the comedy store man
and it was he would he would put the
thing up to him he rewinded put the
thing up to it and my friend and he goes
go say hello and i went over there and i
and i was i looked inside he was
listening i backed up and he goes what
what happened i said no no i saw what i
needed to see he's listening to a set
it's like like that's
i do i do that and i tape all this stuff
then we became you know i became friends
with him so it's a it's a trip to
it's a trip to see a guy in
when my grandmother was alive in the
living room like that we only had one bc
i was in the living room and i had live
in long beach
in 79 80 and i would listen to i would
watch it every [ __ ] day my
grandmother would be like you still
watching that [ __ ] the [ __ ] man not them
fathers like your father's like you
don't have enough you don't get enough
of that they're like no
and
uh you know i ended up
mating them and i eulogized them at his
funeral oh wow
so it's
it's very special yeah that was the only
black guy my mother my grandmother
allowed in the house
and he came and he came in by vcr
[Laughter]
amazing huh okay yeah do another beer or
anything yeah i'll do another one i'm
curious like the sitcom you did what was
it like was that your like first time
first acting thing
yeah
what was that transition like because
you were you how long had you been doing
stand-up before you were acting on that
show
um
20 years
what or close to 20. you were doing
standard 20 years before the show yeah
oh wow on and on at the beginning of the
first five years was on and off oh thank
you so much and then uh about 20 years
and then
you know man it's like it's way
different it was way different then
because you know now because of social
media and all that stuff is that you can
make connections on you know you can
meet anybody anywhere yeah and they can
be helpful to you and you never even
meet them and back then it was like you
had to go
out of your house to go do this and then
um
this guy that i still talked to
said to me in like 99
i heard that he was looking at people
for a producing partner that he had and
that somebody had told him you need to
see george lopez and then he saw me
and then he went away for a whole year
july to july
from 99 to 2000. then he called me in
july 2000 he said are you still
interested in that idea that i have it i
said you you never told me what it was
so in that from july to august i found
out it was uh
uh
sandra bullock
so i met her she came to see me
perform at the improv
and then
like a week later i went to her office
and
we sat down and went over
my act because she said i think that
there's something in there
and then when we had kind of carved out
a bit of a treatment we went to warner
brothers to meet uh
uh bruce helford who did
uh drew carey and roseanne oh sure and
then he told me i didn't know who you
were he was i took the meeting just to
meet sandra
so
i said all right
and uh you know senator just done miss
congeniality so she could open any door
but she was with me the whole time she
never got
never you know we heard a couple knows
but she stayed with me the whole time so
she was just like a huge fan seeing your
stand-up around town
and you've been doing it 20 years prior
to that yeah
and that's so so uh when
i've never taken a entry into trying to
do anything on tv yeah
and um
they were all you know they were all my
stories of like you know my grandmother
my grandfather my life so we we were in
there like talking for like a month
every day and then you know i would cry
a little bit sometimes i would get you
know really kind of sad and the girl
would be typing it down and and she
would go like this and then bruce is
like are you all right and she goes it's
just so sad
[ __ ] typing and i said yeah yeah but
but it's sad but then you know the humor
comes from it yes we were taking almost
like everything like if you had a car
you took it all apart then you're
identifying all of it and then
um
the the pres the president of tv at
warner brothers saw me
in may of 2001 and then the next week
the president of abc and the president
of of warner brothers saw me
on a thursday at the at the ice house
and the next morning
uh bruce suffered called me and said we
got a show man they love you
and that was
that was it and that's the same guy
that's doing lopez versus lopez and
that's the same guy i'm doing the yeah
the show with my daughter it's another
winner wow same same when he was there
yeah
and you know what it's very different
man like like you know you'll appreciate
it like you know i run number one on the
call sheet you know so i i it's it's my
show and you saw me there yes very
inclusive to people and very you know uh
uh welcoming of people and giving people
their credit which is completely
opposite of what a comedian does like
well it's all about us like internally
but but even uh this we shot monday and
tuesday and there's people there that
you know there were extras and people
there and they look at you and you can
tell when they're looking at you like oh
[ __ ] there he is
and
as i stand there and they're touching my
makeup up
i still feel like a comedian
even though i'm an actor in a show yeah
i still feel like
in
aside from all of that that the my
skeleton is a comedian like i might be i
might be acting in a sitcom but the
bones of me are are in comedy i'm the
same way i was watching the george
carlin dock did you see that at all on
hbo and there was a line in there i mean
i'm butchering it but the idea of it is
he's a stand-up comedian and he visits
hollywood right you know what i mean
like and i feel that way too like i'll
i'll step away and visit to do a writing
thing or visit to do an acting thing but
at my core i'm a stand-up community do
you love do you do you
or
do you love it but like stand up but
it's not like if you didn't do it you
died not like that
i mean i like it a lot man yeah i love
it i feel like everything stems from it
right like that is my centering place i
come up it keeps me sharp it gives it
keeps you relevant too because this town
you'll hit something and then you're
down but if you're just doing stand-up
every night
you are in the zeitgeist you are in
control if you're just a straight-up
actor you're kind of you'll have a hot
run for maybe two years three years and
then you're just kind of [ __ ] you're
waiting like hey is anybody you have to
audition right you have to tap dance
yeah vote stand up
it's just you you go you do it
um i think you do you know about uh
manifesting uh manifesting destiny i've
heard about it like the secret and stuff
you put it out there yeah do you believe
in that
a little bit more more and more what is
that to manifest destiny is uh do you
know what it is [ __ ] you seem to
know everything
he's got hyper of course he knows man
for the westward expansion of the united
states oh she is
do you know what manifested like
manifesting in terms of sort of like
creating things
like saying it out loud and then the
universe or saying it to yourself
so
unbeknownst to me
i've been manifesting destiny my my
whole life that you see um
which one do i start with
uh
earlier this year
i was doing a show for amazon and i had
the deal to do
lopez versus lopez and i had a deal to
do an hour at amazon so i shot the hour
at amazon
and
it i thought it came out great amazon
wanted to give it
60 days to think they wanted an
extension of 60 days
february first was the day they had to
say yes or no they said
can we have 60 days to think about it
and in those 60 days
i got the blue beetle did a dc movie the
blue beetle first latino superhero
and that came
two weeks after they asked for the
extension
and then i was able to do
the show with my daughter but if amazon
had picked that show up i wouldn't have
been able to do the blue beetle or the
nbc show
so i
said out loud i'd like to do the show
with my daughter
and what do you have to do to get a dc
movie and they both came in that in that
period
i was in the car damn because i played
golf with don chito and don cheetos and
marvel you know yeah uh war machine and
uh
and playing with him and hearing him
talking about going you know all the
work and stuff
i got in the car and i said what the
[ __ ] do you have to do to get a [ __ ]
dc movie and i got
one
but i think you if you if you
say it out you don't say to anybody but
if you feel it yeah
then you put it out in the universe and
then and i believe that it comes to you
are you gonna get on steroids and get
super ripped
no
no
no
not for this one at least not for no not
for this but but you know i i think you
can you can you know energetically and
and and by things attract things to
you yeah yeah i used to go when i was 15
to the hollywood walk of fame and and
walk up and down and george burns star
would i would imagine my name where
george burns star was in 2006 i got a
star in the walk of fame that's awesome
so i think if you
and i remember i was a guy that
i didn't look at it as love i looked at
it as a
as a form of of a
bit of expression that and i wasn't the
best
you know i would see guys that were way
better who did you like coming up like
um
who was around there um
you know brian regan was a [ __ ] dude
that
was so good technically like a real
comedian and he
cleaned
and never really got like i thought
foxworthy had a tv foxworthy i seen
foxworthy get a show
i saw tim allen before home improvement
and his whole
act he had a showtime special and his
whole act was home improvement the whole
thing with the power tools but [ __ ]
tight
i mean a tight [ __ ] hour like he gave
him the show right like he put it in
their lap and he could that [ __ ] hour
was [ __ ] amazing
and he would do it the same way every
night and he would [ __ ] kill him
every night and you see i saw raymond
get the show i saw kevin get the show i
saw drew carey get a show i saw
uh brad garrett you know from star
search and all that stuff i've seen all
the guys come on i hadn't got an
opportunity and i said man i just you
know not i didn't say like
when's my turn i just it just kind of i
saw i saw somebody or somebody saw me
that was important and they said i think
you know we might have find something in
you and but i never expected to
have these years like the last 20 years
have been yeah it's been amazing yeah
i feel like there was an era of
comedians having their act and you saw
the sitcom yeah i feel like there's less
of that now what do you think the guy's
going out like uh um
who's doing
who's doing shows that are comedians
that
hey fool like that stuff like and
euphoria is anybody a comedian in
euphoria or any of those shows i don't
know if anything you know
yeah
right around because but you know right
so so the special back then the special
was a special it was right it was like
delirious yeah oh my god yeah that was
one of very few [ __ ] specials like
there wasn't 50 specials delirious
yeah yeah
george carlin did him and then robert
klein and rodney danger had stuff but
they were that's why they called them a
special and now i think with
there's just so many
there's comedy central there's show time
there's hbo there's stars there's
youtube now everyone like myself
included you know that's why i did mine
at the store i'm like okay i have to
separate myself somehow
because if i did it at some black box
theater it may be funny material but who
gives a [ __ ] like there's so many of
them you could have a thousand chocolate
chip cookies and then you're like
this doesn't move me anymore
would you would you do you do you act do
you take uh yeah i mean stan was the
main thing and then an acting thing or a
writing thing that's two different
things
uh
what stand up and acting or writing
acting oh yeah yeah yeah that's why i
was kind of curious so when you started
acting in your sitcom
was it supernatural for you
no no no no you know in 2001 december
2001 i i did i read with the guy who
became my best friend of the show he was
an actor actor yeah and
i'd already been writing the show with
these guys for like four months but
nobody ever asked me hey can you act
nobody ever said can you hang it so so
bruce and robert the other guys go hey
read with uh valente we read
and i was [ __ ] awful
that was awful and i we had wrote the
script already
and i was off when i looked at them and
it's almost like you know if you have a
kid out there and your kids you know
you're like what's that [ __ ]
doing is he all right like they were
looking at me like
and i said and then they said to me oh
no no you don't have to read it's cool
it's all right you're good
but i saw in their eyes
the fear of like this [ __ ]
connect so i went back and i got myself
an acting coach like that day and then i
just i used her for the whole run of my
show every week
because i you know
would talk in one tone i was like i
would talk like this at the whole time
hey man there's a car behind you watch
out it's gonna hit you i wouldn't say
like hey it's a car you know yeah i was
very monotone
and uh my eyes would move everywhere
and and enacting you they you can't do
that so
she taught me and this is how [ __ ]
this is how [ __ ] green i was as an
actor so
you have your side over there i have it
and i and i said i would say to her
uh
say it to me
what do you mean say it i want to hear
it say it to me
okay well you have to act with me no no
i'll memorize this i'll take it home and
then but i want to hear you
do it because that's not for [ __ ]
actors
i couldn't even read to her
and i already had a deal to do a show i
couldn't even
read to me and her when did you feel
comfortable do you think like what at
what point [ __ ] man um maybe
uh
you know we did four mid-season and uh
the biggest decision i had ever had to
make
was
[Music]
abc bought the show
so
they were like do you wait till
september
and 9 11 already happened 2001 the year
before and and all the comedies went
away
because uh you know it was yeah
nobody wanted to laugh
so
they said you can go mid-season
or you could wait till september so we
were all at warner brothers in the
president's office sandra me bruce
robert warner brothers people abc people
were on the speakerphone
and we were deciding when to go
and
they said you guys want to go at the end
of march or do you want to go in
september
and sandra goes well let's ask george
like what do you want to do
and i said uh
i said hey let's go in march i said if
we're gonna find out let's find out
sooner than later and it was the best
i think it was the best move i could
have made
if i waited till september i think i
would have lost the momentum
of the interest from i think it would
have still been there
but
we went for it
quick to get in to get a quick answer
and then we got picked up
so after we had to we had to retain
85 percent of the lead in
uh
and we retained 93 of the lead-in so
they picked it up and then i had the
summer off we started to write and then
we're off and going yeah but i mean
that decision was not going to be made
like sandra was like you should be the
one who makes the decision not us
what do you want to do
and i was like i didn't i didn't know
from anything i said hey let's go
you know let's go in the end of march so
it worked out that worked out i was they
made too many mistakes what was the lead
in show do you remember uh
according to jim
uh oh well
watch four more episodes well there's
the same one on american airlines the
other day
okay still going on manifest destiny i'm
on a flight
with kevin james
uh
and he's in first class and i'm not i'm
in i'm in coach
and they have the tv in front of the
seat
and he's watching king of queens so he's
with the dude and he's and they're both
watching the show yeah i go to the
bathroom walk by him i don't really know
him hey what's up
and i can from where i'm sitting i can
see them pointing at the screen and
saying this they're talking about the
show giving notes and i said i said
i would like one day
to be on a plane and see my show uh on a
tv screen on an airplane
and
it happened
it's there today where'd you where did
you see it i was on the way back from
miami
just uh last week
how many seasons uh 120 shows six
residuals babies
yeah and they had four episodes and see
i watched all four goddamn episodes
and then and then i watched the movie
and the movie was good it was a shoot em
up i can't find the gut i can't find the
ending of it now
10 minutes
before the end of the movie they turn
the thing off we're getting ready to
laugh because i wasted your [ __ ] time
in the first half exactly yeah the
flight for the next one you're like i
gotta see how this ends
i'll take a bus but but uh yeah so so
but
as like a comedian comedian you know
like that's what what i was
uh
to have
a show and to to do that to drive on the
lot like i'm over at nbc yeah and all
that [ __ ] you got the parking spot
george lopez right there by the
the stage
it's where did you guys shoot warner
brothers we shot the first one at warner
brothers
and then uh yeah we shot the first one i
wanted brother and then this one at uh
so freddie prinze
i used to watch sanford and son growing
up it was on friday night at eight and
chico and man was on at 8 30. so freddie
prince was my idol and then san
francisco i really really loved so my
time spot
uh is the
saffron sun time spun
friday night at eight
manifest
good for you brother it's a weird
landscape for comedians because that was
the blueprint you know like it's not
anything when i was growing up that was
the thing to do even when i got into
stand-up like all right that's the
blueprint
you stand up get a sitcom get on a
sitcom it just helps with ticket sales
on the road right that's like not a
thing anymore what do you want what does
is money import is it money important
it's part of it like i don't need a
lamborghini and [ __ ] i just want
stability and they make
a living is your creative more towards
in front of the cam like like would a
sitcom be good for you
or even if it was like on a
what hbo max or hulu or amazon something
different yeah yeah yeah yeah that'd be
cool just like something of your own
creation you know like what you got to
do is great yeah it's very much you your
ideas your life
anything like that you know what let me
tell you let me tell you a story
i was drinking on a sunday night with my
friend memo at their mission hills and
we drank
uh you know a case
each maybe
two six
beers 14 and i was driving
and i had this uh um uh volkswagen
scirocco that had a great stereo in it
and every time i went back to the liquor
store i put the music on louder and it
wasn't that far like i still remember
driving i was i was [ __ ] drunk
but i still remember
driving i wasn't blacked out but the
cops passed us
and what got their attention was i had
the radio so loud they looked
and they went back and pulled me over
had the radio
so
they they pulled me over i was [ __ ]
drunk
walked the thing they arrested me
went to
foothill division in the morning they
chained me to some dude
we went around to all the other uh
divisions and picked up other [ __ ]
drunk drivers or guys that right it took
us to van nuys to arraign us you know to
to for an arraignment and when i was
sitting in
in the set holding cell of van nuys
courthouse
uh
three guys in orange jumpsuits comment
one is a heavier set latino guy with
blonde hair
and i'm looking down like this
and he sits next to me and he's got uh
uh you know slippers on but it's his
toes are painted like like red
[Music]
and i look down like this and i go i
look at his toes and i look
and he's got like
it's a dude he's got on locks crazy hair
and red toes
and i look up and it's just a heavy guy
that's very faith that orange toenails
and [ __ ] blond hair and the sheriff
comes to the door and he goes lopez
and i stood up
and the dude next to me stood up our
last names are lopez and the and the
sheriff guy goes
no mrs lopez
when i did my sitcom i put
that scene in the show
where i was arrested and the guy comes
and goes lopez and there was a [ __ ] in
the corner i remember he lifted himself
up like this like very kind of like a a
ballerina and he goes and the guy goes
mrs lopez and the guy went out there i
put the same [ __ ] scene
in the show word for work yeah i was
just gonna say that sounds like it
worked out good in your show now
call back
i already use it though you wanna go but
so you so you know i mean it's like it's
like i think our currency
is our thoughts but also our currency is
like our experiences yeah if somebody
you know if somebody says something to
you and you're like wow i never really
heard anybody [ __ ] put it like that
is that's how that's our
our fuel
yeah view them what your dad would have
say to you when he was upset with you or
what my grandmother had said to me
you know
or i said i said uh hey grandma want to
be a comedian like okay
a comedian
how are you going to be a community i'm
going to go over to the place
i'm funnier than you
take me with you i'll [ __ ] be a
comedian too will you still hit mics at
all or what will you do no no no no no
stand up
no you know what one time i went to uh i
went to go i went to dinner we were
driving by the comedy store with this
girl i said i used to go out there like
saturday night there's all kinds of
people outside and i said i used to go
out there and wait like these guys and
we went by
the la factory there's people out there
and then i thought about it
on the way home and uh
when i got home i got sick like i threw
up oh really yeah
it that the idea of
of being out there
again like remembering what it was like
to be out there
made me like baby sick
yeah
you know
that was your jojo's
but you know because it is because it is
it is
i mean it's
it's a grind
some people never
you know there's some people that
there's there's really no there's no
thing set right of who
who comes up and who doesn't come up
like there's no
there's no pattern or there's no path
you can truly take everybody's path is
different totally yeah so there's no
there's no way that
you go oh i should have gone and done
that that would have made it better no
no because
you just got to do it you just got to do
it what did you how did you feel how did
you find chappelle how does chappelle
find you well that was just like a show
in austin so i when things were really
shut down here during the pandemic
i missed stand up because we couldn't do
shows out here and then i had this
writing job that was all over zoom for
so i'm like if i'm zooming i could be
anywhere right and austin was open doing
stand-up and i go all right that'd be
cool to just like
zoom right by day and then do stand up
at night
so i know rogan you know and like he was
like hey do you want to do this show at
uh stubs they were doing outdoor shows
so then you know i did that show out in
um
austin it was great like chappelle was
on it you know michelle wolf rogan it
was so cool just to be yeah because we
didn't have that for so long you know to
be deprived of it right and you you have
that rapport with an audience and that
fills this
you take away your identity for a bit
you're like what am i without stand up
you know and then so it's cool to do it
out there
and then when things kind of got back to
normal here in light then i came back so
when you're on the road uh where are you
going to be you want to want to mention
any place yeah uh let's see dallas is
this weekend where where at
improv and then wise guys salt lake city
that is
why addison's a good club yeah and then
i did a lot of shows in addison uh-huh
yeah i've done it before i like that
club and then i'm doing uh what can i
tell you a story about this story yeah
so i knew a latina girl
um in addison and she said my boss is
coming with his wife
and she goes so can you um not use so
much profanity because
they're real i said i don't give a [ __ ]
if they're [ __ ] religious or not so
they come to the show i just do my
normal show
and we after the show we're drinking and
they're starting to loosen up and we go
to uh
a dance club down the street
and
they were getting a little bit loose
we were dancing in the middle of the
dance floor and she got on her knees and
took that dude's dick out and blew him
on the dance club
and they threw them out and i said to
her oh
i can't say the f word but she can
[ __ ] suck his dick in the middle of a
dance floor and it wasn't even hard it's
like pulling the phone
getting your sleep caught in the [ __ ]
door and doing it
it's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] skin
right there and she just pulling like
this taffy you know you're like and i
look down at you and you're like what
the [ __ ]
and it just like that was ground zero
everybody took off and you just see her
right there they [ __ ] threw him out
man
and the girl was there they took off
driving drunk and i said oh no i can't
say the f word but
she's pulling [ __ ] taffy in the
middle of the [ __ ] dance floor
shout out addison texas shout out to
addison we'll see if that happens when
i'm there crazy [ __ ] uh there was also a
time that uh there was this girl in the
front row in addison beautiful [ __ ]
top stripes oh hey it's trying to say
you know so she was with her bro she was
with a dude and you know you're [ __ ]
with her and she go that's my brother
like oh yeah okay i [ __ ] my brother
too
and then afterwards we go and have some
drinks and then
she comes back to my
my hotel room
and
in the morning i had to go do radio of
course like thursday night friday i go
to the wait i said i said hey i'll be
back in a couple hours she goes okay
i'll be right here
and when i come in the door it's still
dark in there and she's not around and
i'm like
what the where did she go got a thing in
that bag
right i go to the bathroom and i had
taken my underwear off and i had
[ __ ] stains in my underwear
so i think she got to use the bathroom
and saw my [ __ ] underwear
[Laughter]
you had the skid mark but she hit the
road
[Music]
thank you
and i said why did she leave i looked
down
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
i got nothing about wise guys it's only
about that yeah oh but yeah man thanks
for coming on course man thank you very
much nice to meet you man i appreciate
where your heart is and uh and thank you
for loving stand-up man yeah sam and
everybody that's out there that listens
go and check my man out please i look at
the date too for uh wise guys assault
like that september 16th yeah then house
of comedy in october just more tour
dates at fahimanuar.com you take
somebody with you or or sometimes when i
can you know i'm in this in between
where sometimes they're like oh we want
a local person but then sometimes i can
bring a boy out and it's like nice if i
ever come out there oh yeah i would love
to man that'd be awesome
all right good awesome thanks for coming
out of course man thanks guys
you